this is one of those rare times when I
look at the tomato meter on Rotten
Tomatoes and I truly do not understand
what I see in kick-ass 2 we pick up
again with Hit Girl and kick-ass himself
and they're dealing with some real-world
problems they're all dealing with the
fact the world isn't really made for
people who want to be superheroes people
can die they'll get beat up they'd get
killed you know it happens all the time
in the real world and in kick-ass 2 we
get to see a lot of those teams develop
as Christopher mintz-plasse I think I
said that right and he's creating his
own supervillain army to finally go up
against kick-ass and their new army led
by Colonel stars and stripes or Jim
Carrey no I apologize that I had this
review up a little bit late I got really
sick in the middle of the week and I
missed the screening so I went and saw
it today so I had the opportunity to
actually for once see the Rotten
Tomatoes score before I saw the movie
usually I get to actually review the
movie before the score is out which I
really like because it helps me not to
think about things but coming out of
this movie I can't believe how low the
score was I really enjoyed this movie it
was a lot of fun I almost liked it
pretty much the same as the first one it
might not have been on the exact level
but I really enjoyed this movie quite a
bit and I thought it was a good fun
summertime movie that we've kind of been
lacking a lot of the times this summer
Aaron taylor-johnson as kick-ass was
really good in this movie he definitely
is able to play younger than his age
because he's obviously way older than
his character in this movie but he did a
really convincing job with it and he
also was fun and cool in the action
scenes he had a great wit to him he was
funny he was also pretty good in the
dramatic scenes and I thought he did a
great job as a character again but just
like the first movie the supporting
character that really steals the show is
once again Hit Girl Chloe grace Moretz
is awesome in this movie she does a
great job with all the action scenes
she's funny in the movie too she has a
really cool subplot actually where she
has to try to be a normal girl and I
really like the way the film told that
story because they showed how she
couldn't really escape that person she
just tried to always find different ways
to be Hit Girl without actually being
Hit Girl at this school and I really
like that let's talk about Jim Carrey in
the movie now I know there's a lot of
controversy with him and his whole thing
about the whole no guns thing and look
that's his opinion that's fine I'm not
really gonna get into that because it
doesn't have anything to do with the
movie he did a great job in the movie as
usual he's terrific with physical humor
you can tell he was doing his stunts and
everything and he was really great in
the movie he has this one hilarious shot
where he just like slams himself into
this guy I busted out laughing I
we thought he did a good job in the
movie my only problem with him is that I
didn't think he was in the movie enough
I wanted him to have more screen time
but I really did like his character and
I had a lot of fun with him honestly
this is just a fun movie and if you go
into it expecting anything other than
Mother Russia an incredibly manly woman
just breaking snapping necks all over
the place
you're going to be disappointed no it's
not a perfect movie and I do have flaws
with it a lot of the drama in the movie
is very heavy-handed and at times it
doesn't work there are dramatic scenes
that are supposed to really hit you in
the gut and it doesn't really work
because it feels very rushed there are
certain elements of the action scenes
that felt a little too shaky some of the
green-screen is really crappy just like
the first film about some of the green
screen the first film wasn't that good
either certain villainous characters are
introduced during the first half of the
movie that seemed to kind of fade away
and they don't have much to do with the
movie and then they just sort of
disappear and then there's a big evil
army and it just kind of happens really
fast I would say that's probably my
biggest flaw with the movie is that a
lot of it feels a little bit too rushed
but for the most part I had a really
good time with kick-ass - I think it's a
fun summer movie if you go into it
expecting anything other than a 15 year
old girl kicking ass then you know why
did you expect that I'm going to give
kick-ass - a b-plus so guys did you see
the movie what'd you think of it what do
you think the first one let me know
below and as always thanks very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
Oh